-this, but some of you actually may not
and I'm speaking for those of you from the future right now
I know that the livestream has not started just yet
but, I wanted to say hello because
I know this game
It-it's, it's actually...it looks older than it actually is
But I played this first about two years ago
and oddly enough I'm starting the stream on time
so that's why I'm talking to you guys
and I'm doin' all this stuff in the meantime
BUT
for now
*sniff*
I'm gonna talk about
*deep breath*
Power Drill Massacre while I'm doin' this
because I always meant to play it again.
I only played it one time, and then I always said like;
"THIS GAME WAS SOO COOL!"
and then I was always intending to come back to it
and yet I didn't...so...
here I am, almost two years later
getting back into the game
and it's been updated!
I mean it's not fully released yet, apparently
uh
I don't even know if the development has been halted at all
but this was always a really cool game
just in the way that it was very very retro.
It was a super super retro game
and that kind of led it to be this super...
super weird
really interesting
uh game
and HELLO everybody who is watching me live now
so hello hello hello.
How ya guys doin?!
Welcome to; Power Drill Massacre
Now
I'm gonna go ahead and start the game here just makin sure everything is honkey dorey
on theeee.....
stream-front yes?
Hello?
Hi?
Can you see me? Tell me if you guys can see me.
Yeah?
I'm not late!?
I'm not late at all. What are you guys talkin' about? I'm right on time.
So anyway...
So we're gonna get goin' here.
We've got a lot to work on.
and we've got a lot to do. So I'm
going to go ahead and get in the game here, aaaand start a new one
because
if you guys remember this
uuuuh
...things don't go so well
if you recall, when we're in this environment here
things don't go-ah heyo there's everybody.
Hi. How ya doin' everybody?
Shhh!
It's very important plot.
*awkward breath* yeah...
But if you remember, this doesn't go so well from
the very get go
but I always loved the retro styling of it.
Like the VHS look to it.
It just..it kinda-it kinda set the tone
for the old
*sniff*
80's style horror movie.
The very campy...ya know
cliche ridden, but still
*Dastardly Mark voice* Murderous and gory and bloody murder scene that was here
and oh what a beautiful painted sunset that is.
*incomprehensible game audio*
Uh-huh.......
*more audio*
Uh-huh.
Uh-huh!
*audio stops*
uh-huh!!
Uh-huh...
How old am I? I'm 27.
*screams from game audio*
Aaahh!!
*car crash sound effect*
Crash!
Alrighty then...
As you can see...
not a good start to this adventure, but...
allow us to go even further down into the depths of depravity-
-Jeff!
My *chuckle* my name-a...
Your name-a Jeff?!
Are you okay?
"Ugh...I can't..."
*sniff*
"I can't name-a my legs."
"Don't worry Jeff. I'll go get help."
Yeah...I'm sure I'm gonna do that.
I don't remember if that plot was there in the beginning.
I only loaded-a this up to test.
Heh! *dopey voice* "This is the worst headache ever..."
Yeah...the death headache...from a car crash.
"But I think I'm alright."
"It's getting dark. Better get the flashlight out of the trunk."
Alright.
So...the way is camere...oh...ugh...
Is Jeff in there?
Jeff, how ya doin' in there?
Jeff?
Jeff just looks like a mangled corpse.
Ha-I don't think Jeff is gonna make it here.
Alright so.
*sniff*
The camera is just the tiniest bit wonky here.
So lemme just see if I can...
Ya how do I...
"My flashlight pick it up?"
Yeah, lets go ahead with yes.
*old school sci-fi sound*
Alright. So the 'use' button is space...oddly enough.
Ah there we go.
Any of you remember this?
Is this bringing back any memories for you guys?
Oh yeah.
Uh
DON'T WORRY MY NAME-A JEFF!
I'm gonna come back fer you!!-
*ominous music*
Ooooh....
HohoHOhoo...
Ooh boy
*Music continues*
♪Doot doot♪ Hi!
*chuckle* What's my name?
I always...
I never-
Mary! That was right.
Aaaahhh....
The good ol' somber tones of the...
*music peters out eerily*
Orchestra...
Ah.
So we're not doing the um...
We're not doing the...the, the fixed orbital camera for this one
Just because
I remember trying to do that and just navigating
was always just a...bit of a bare.
Anyway...we're gonna skedaddle over here.
I cant remember if there was a stamina bar for running but
*deep breath*
Uh...I never made it very far.
I'm just gonna go ahead and say that right now.
If you didn't see the first time I played this which...
If you did I recommend watching it.
It was an extremely scary game
Uhm, back in the day.
And uh, if they've made any improvements to it
it's still...extremely scary.
For how...
Like you guys...who have never seen this before are prolly like...
*cocky voice* "Daawe Mark! What are ya talkin' about? This looks like garbo!"
No....you don't know.
You, you have no idea what you're in for
Oh, but I do.
I know exactly what you're in for.
and we gotta make our way over here.
I need to help-a my name-a Jeeefff!
I gotta help-a mah Jeeff!
Eheh! So the only way to get help...
is to walk arou...along this-
Woah.
Wait, what is that?
Hang on I don't know if that-was that bear there before?
I can't remember...
Th-anyway....just walking along this narrow, sheer, cliff's edge...
and just hope for the best as you careen off into the depth..
"What a creepy old shed."
"It's boarded up."
Yeah! Creepy and old!
Just like everything here huh?
Oh! Satanic symbol?
"Looks like some kids drew a pentagram back here."
Yeah... some kids...
on a creepy shed....
in the middle of nowhere....
...where yer definitely not gonna get murdered...
Alright. So everybody. If you haven't already; turn down your lights.
Crank up the volume to high because,
*deep breath*
we're about to make our way to the manor
of murder, power drill, massacreness.
So
cuddle up in your blanket if-a you think it will help ya which...
probably won't considering all the murder that's about to happen- Oh...
Uh oh!
The signal's getting interrupted.
I mean I always appreciated this retro styling for these games.
Actually
*sniff*
uhm
the game 'Friday The 13th' is gonna be comin' out very soon.
which is...Jason Voorhees in all of his glory
So, I don't know...uh
I think...isn't that like a multiplayer only type game?
Which is unfortunate if it is but
I still kinda wanna play it-
*ominous chime*
Ahh....
Hi...
Hello!
What a nice warehouse you've managed to park up on-
w-Oooh....
Hi up there!...
Who's there?!
I see you!...
Hellloo?!
Okay, goodbye then!...
Fare thee well.
Alright so...if I recall correctly...
I di-I think this one is v-very defunct...
Not that I even know how-
Neh-Just a "Just a junked car. Nothing interesting inside."
But how did it get up here?!
I had to walk up a sheer mountain cliff to get up here.
You just wandered up the side path...
Alright, I don't think any of these doors actually work.
I these are all just garbo trickster doors.
"I can't use this door, it's rusted shut."
Yeah you're not strong enough to open it.
*ominous chime*
Uh oh...
Bing bong...
"This door is SEALED shut."
Not rusted....sealed...
...and I don't think I can go that way. So...
Oooh that's beautiful though!
So I'm gonna go...
Uhps...into that bush.
...and then I'm gonna go in here
and then I'm gonna die.
I'm hesitant
because I know how badly I'm going to die.
I know how extremely I'm going to die.
I know how excessively death is going to approach me.
Aaoh boy...
Yeah...
You guys good? You guys good over there?
Yeah? you guys good?
Okay. You don't have a blanket? Well..
tough shit for you I guess. You're about ta get...
Yer-you're about ta get
Unprotected
When it comes to all these horrors with which you have never seen.
Alright.
Hello?
"This door is open. Go inside?"
Yeah sure why not.
You know...
"What a creepy building."
But why not? Maybe they got a phone...
Hi...
oh-OH god jesus, that eye.
Okay...
So *door locks*
*deep breath of regret*
Yeah...
So uh...
If you guys recall...
I'm...immediately in danger.
From the second I step in this building...
I'm immediately in danger...
because ya see that rolling shutter-
Ya know what?!
I'm not gonna spoil it for you guys*crying chuckle*
because things is about to go down.
and oh man.
I don't even know why it took me so long to play this game again.
It kinda like...
It was one of those games where
I played it
I loved it
It was amazingly horrifying
and then I just didn't play it again.
and I don't know why...
Ah hello...are you important?
"Looks like an article ripped out of a news paper. Read it?"
"'The search continues for two missing campers in the Pocono Mountains."
"Mason C. Sargent ad Laurie Summers of Long Island New York"
"-have been missing."
"Since june 8th, their campsite and belongings"
"have located but investigators have few leads"
"Police say there are no visible signs of a struggle"
"and this continues to be a rescue mission."
"The rest is missing."
"dated August ta-1982. "
"5 years ago."
Oh yes indeed...
"Looks like a key...pick it up?"
Yup.
"You got a key with blue plaint spat-"
*old school sci-fi sound*
"paint splattered on it."
Ooh, there's about to be a lot of red paint splattered on the walls
if I ain't gonna be able ta get away from the guy that's in here...
So in case you're curious uhm..
there's a reason it's called
Power Drill Massacre
I don't know where...
Where oh where...
I-I vaguely...vaguely
remember the layout of this place.
Just barely
remember the layout of this place. It's not
It's not entirely user friendly in terms of the navigation over here
But uh...
Doin' mah best...doin' mah best guys.
*creepy ambience*
I can't remember if those sounds are actually him
Or...what...
Uh.
Uh!
Hello?
Hi...
Anybody here?
No?
Okay...
So I'm looking for...
I'm looking for a door....
Oh, I forgot that just looped over there.
I'm looking for a door-
ugh...
I gotta stay clear of those blue shutter doors...
Cause that's bad news...
But I'm looking for a blue door...
and I don't remember where it is.
This place is much bigger than you thin-
*thump*
*Mark gasps*
Is that a bad sign?!?!
Is that a BAD sign?!?
Ayeyayayayayayayayayayayaye...
Sugar tunnel?!
Oooh don't go in the sugar tunnel!
I forgot about the sugar tunnel!
You don't wanna GO in the sugar tunnel!
The sugar tunnel is baaaAAAAaaaad news bubba.
Bad bad news...
Oh boy...
Death...death...
*footsteps*
AAAAhaaaAA!!!
What the fuck!??!
AAAAAaaagGHH FUCKING what THE FFfuck!!?!...
I ran the wrong way.
Ran the wrong way.
Ran right into a dead end I did.
That's not good. Okay. So anyway...
I uh...
Yeah so I-I got drilled
I got drilled. Yeah. Real easy...
That's uuuhm...
*door locks*
*SNIFF*
That's what this games all about *Crying*
That's what this games ALL about.
That's the only warning you get.
Footsteps...and you're deahehehehehead!
and you are dead, and unfortunately the blue key
spawns in random locations so
Uh I've already read this...
I just wanted to read it again.
Awh shit.
It's like the owl from Zelda.
Hokay so..
Yeah that's all ya get!
It's all ya get.
Naw that's all ya get guys.
That's all you get.
*sigh of regret*
Oh you wanna see what's in the sugar tunnel? *Laughs*
You guys wanna see what's in the sugar tunnel?!
Oooh hoho ya dont!
Ya really dooon't!
Bu you know what
I don't even know if I can get IN the sugar tunnel
but sure...why not.
You know you guys are just so eager beavers about it...
*Deeper voice* We're gonna go down into the sugar tunnel...
and you guys are gonna see exactly why I don't wanna go in the sugar tunnel. *cries*
*sniff*
The sugar tunnel is an unfriendly
unforgiving place of death! *more crying*
Uuuhhhh...shhhhit.
Oh boy.
Oh no, wait. That's not the right way. This is the right way.
Oh I forgot, there's an upstairs. I think I need to go up there
But uh...first
Lets-HEEY!...
I don't remember that being there!
Did you guys see that?!
Did you guys see that?
Or was it...wha...
Am I just goin out of my mind or did you guys see a little kid just run by?
Welp
It probably just came from the sugar tunnel so...
Here we GO into the SUGAR TUNNEL!
Toot toot!
Oh, where is it?
I forget.
I forget where it is...
Is this it?
Yeah this is-THIS is it!
OH this is the sugar tunnel...
Oh boy...
Aaah gawd...heh
Yup...here we go....
we're now in the SUGAR TUNNEL!!
*sniff*
HAAAAaaaaye don't wanna be here!!
Oh I don't wanna be- Oh, that's a dead end...
Uh oh...
uh oh
Uuuh what was that that!?
What did I just see?
UH
uh
I don't know what I just saw but it wasn't good....
yiih..
nnn...
*scared noise*
Stop that! You stop tha-
You stop that right now with those flashes!
The fuck was that?
*louder sound*
STOP IT!!!
*sound*
NooOOO!
Don't do that...
*sound*
No no no noo no...
No!!
*sound*
AAAAGH! HE'S RIGHT BEHIND ME!
No?
*sigh of momentary relief*
Okay...
alright...
Ah.
I vaguely remember this.
I vaguely...
vaaaguely remember this...
I VAGUELY remember this!...
Oooh no...
OOH no..
Oh no, it was a goddamn loop.
Oh yeah!
I think that's a place where you can lose him if he's chasing you in the sugar tunnels.
Which is a good idea...
I mean it's a bad idea in general to be down here in the first place but...
ya know..
Woah. Did I see something behin-*thud*
*loud gasp*
Pokay...
Sstop that!
No flashes!
No FLASHES here!
uh oh...
...k...
I think I might have made it out of here...
Stop that!!!
*footsteps*
AAGH!
NOO!
NOT IN THE SUGAR TUNNEL!!!!
NOOO NONONONO!!!
Oooh no!!
Is this toxic slime!?!!
*whirring noises*
AAAOOOHH FUCKING NO!
*footsteps and distant screaming*
No No No No No No No No NNOOAAAAOOOOOO!!!!!
*high pitched scream*
OOOH God Oh God Oh God!!!!
Oh God Oh God I don't know where I am!!!
OOOH God It's The Kids Room Of Death!!!
NOOOOOOOO!!!!
AAAaahfff-
*whimpering woman in background*
Whhaaa?
Wha?
Ooooh no. HI!!!
*woman screams*
Nononono!
Nonononono!
No!
I don't know what happened...
Did you kidnap me?
Oh hi!
Okay....
Oooh okay...
Goodbye then!.....
*flies buzzing*
*footsteps*
*incomprehensible mumbling*
WHAT?!
*mumbling continues*
Whaahheheheheehehe
What in the world has happened to me? *cry laughing*
*music box plays Green Leaves*
Nooohohohoho!! You stop that!
That is not okay!!!
That's NOT okay!...
*loud whirring noises*
AAAUUGGH!!!
OOOoooooh.....
*screaming and drilling continues*
Okay....
Alright!....
What!?
Wha-That was the END!!?!?
I somehow reached....
The ENDING?!!??!
WHAT?!?!?!
HOW in the HELL?!
I don't even know what happened!!!
Dude...I don't even know...
I don't even know what happened...
I don't even know what happened
That was messed up.
But I-I know that's not THE end of the game...
Cause there's other things you can do in the game but...
Oh my god!
Yeah sorry everybody's ears but oh man!
That was messed up.
Alright let's try this again.
Alright hang on I gotta...
*Deep exhale/sigh*
Okay!
Scheezums...
Alright.
Let's try loading the game up.
See if that's gonna go anywhere...
No?
Uh oh!
Oh there's no- there's no game to load anymore?
Wha- I gotta start over again?!
Well, shit, then!
Alright, I'll go back into it, but, man!
So, th-the secret of that is, uh,
don't go in the goddamn sugar tunnels!
And THAT'S why!
*High pitched* THAT'S WHY!
Don't go in there!
It's a HORRIBLE place!
It's a HORRIBLE place of DEATH!
And destruction for everybody to see...
It's awful.
Some fuckin' weirdo...
Goddamnit...
Oh...
Thank you, Kevin B., who said:
"Hi, Mark, I just wanted to say what an inspiration you've been to me. Your videos and your words have gotten me
through the hardest times of me life. Yesterday was my birthday, and I'm so glad I'm getting to watch you play
this now."
Well, happy birthday, Kevin, and happy birthday to everybody out there.
What better way to spend your birthday
than a car crash that leads you to go into a manor of
death and dismemberment.
That's a good way to spend a birthday in MY book.
So, I'm gonna rush back to the place,
and, uh, hopefully
hopefully, I'm not gonna go in the sugar tunnels anytime soon.
Cause I think the sugar tunnels are just
kind of bad for my overall health.
Ah, my name-a Jeff
My name-a Jeff I'm gonna help you
Jeff please- Oh god
Where- Woah- Where am I?
Alright
There we go
Let's skeddadle back as soon as the
Soon as the light clears outta my goddamn face here
Alright, skeddidily-doo~
Skeddidily-doo~
I'm scoodling-a-doodling
*trails off as ominous music plays*
Oah
Well then...
Ah, that's much better
I can see finally
*ominous music continues to play*
Heh, the ducks will keep me safe
I don't think those ducks are gonna be able to stop the Power Drill Massacre murderer
Uuugh..
And why a power drill?
Why a power drill?
It seems like just absolutely unnecessary for this endeavor
And I know..
Also I wanted to point out
That this person has made - whoever's the developer of this one is -
Maybe I can use the building in the distance
Like..
Whoever made this - they've made other games like this
I don't think I've played them though
I can't remember if I have or not but they've made other games like this
and this was the most recent one
Um..
And other than that I can't remember if there was anymore progress to be made on that
but I wanted to say..
To the developer..
This is awesome! Like you've gotta keep doing this. Like these - these - tha -
as low res, and as low graphics as it is it still captures the good, terrifying, claustrophobic game play of it
and just the messed up brutal nature of it all
like that's good. And you should keep doing that because
Like it's sometimes hard to capture that feeling
of terror and like
just utter helplessness and this game captures it very well
And so it- it- it may not be great in terms of graphical fidelity but in terms of like utilizing
the graphics to tell a story of the time that it's made in and also using the VHS like overlays and whatnot
to emphasize that and also cranking up the audio of it
and making the audio very good because even here in the ambiance y-you don't even notice it because it's good
but you hear..
Like the wind rhistling -
- whistling through and like the
the - the - the crickets and the stuff; it all sets a tone..
For this..
Timeline and the game and the horror of it and I really do appreciate it. I know -
I know it's sometimes hard to get that across but I really do appreciate it.
So
We're back in here
So hopefully that blue key's gonna be there
Blhh
O-kay
Or I'm gonna bug the game out and go into the building the WRONG way
Errybody hold on there
Errybody hold onto your hats. I don't know. I think I transcended reality there for a second
Well let's try this again shall we?
Shoobity-boop
Shaboobi-dee-doop
Can I go in here?
Alright, "this door is open". "Go inside?"
Yeah sure. Alright.
So other than that
Auuh
Come on
Let's see.. Alright, here we go.
So..
Clickity-click-click!
Okay that's fine. I don't know who did that, but, good for them
Whaat- THEFUCKINGNO!!
*markimoo facepalm*
*regretting life choices*
*sassy lip smack*
*tastes like defeat*
I think I just remembered; running in the halls is bad news
but also it seems like this guy's already chasing someone through these halls
That's no good..
That's no good. That's so unfaaair
Okay, but it looks like the blue key might be here
"You got a key with GREEN paint splattered on it"
So
I don't remember where the green door was?
But I do know I need to take it a little more cautiously around here
because I don't remember how to get away from him
I don't even know
I don't even remotel- *gasp*
UH
*footsteps*
AH.
AAAAAAAAAAHH!
FUCKINGNO!
*rip mark*
*laugh of defeat* Oh no..
*inhale*
Aaahahahaha..
*sniffle*
I forget that they change some things they're like.. I can't remember
There's a way 'cause I've gotten pretty far in this game
I don't think there's like a - there's no hiding mechanic, there's no..
..creeping mechanic, there's no..
You can just walk and hope for the best
Oh the key's not there anymore
Oooh.. Heheheheh..
*hopeless laughing continues*
*laughing slowly turning insane*
Oh boy..
OH BOY-O
Oooh boy-o oh boy oh boy oh boy
I don't wanna go in the sugar tunnel :(
I don't wanna go..
Oooh boy-o
Alright this isn't the sugar tunnel right there
I'm just gonna travel through this area
okay..
Okay..
Now I don't remember..
I don't like those footsteps I'm hearin'
Oh that's open- yeah that's right that shutter's open- that's how you get in the sugar tunnel
You don't wanna go in there
Not again
Okay
But
There should be something else here
There should be somethin'..
I remember there's like a stairs up
That I can go to- yeah here
And there's something up there
I belie- *gasp*
*footsteps*
AAAH NO!
NO!
I think I'm- I think me running is what's ca-
I thin-
I think me running-
ahahaha
I think me running is what's doing a bad
How much blood?
How much blood do I possibly have in me?
How much blood
could I possibly have
in my body..?
I don't know but I don't think it's enough
Aaalright
Let's try this once more
Or at least a couple more times before I give up on it
'kay this time I'm jus' gonna walk
I'm not gonna try- can I hide in these?
No these are vending machines I can't hide in those
But I- I ga- I remember there's some way
Some way to survive this because
it can't just be running
I know it's not just running
I know there's something to this; some trick
Something
'cause you can get the keys..
You can get the keys..
And you can get something here
"Another newspaper article."
"Pocono vanishings: No trace of missing campers. April 4th 1985. Since 1978, twelve campers have disappeared over a" -
-"100 mile stretch of the Pocono Mountains. "We conduct dozens of rescue missions each year" says Park Ranger Charlie Plank. "People come up here'" -
-"'to camp and hike all the time without any experience. Accidents happen" While most rescues are successful these 12 have stumped park rangers and local police.''"-
-'"Campfires left burning, boots and jackets left behind, radios still playing. It's like these people were ripped away from their campsites" says Abe Bradley who was involved in the search for'" -
"I can't read anymore. The ink has faded."
Okay
So that's like the story and I've never really been able to piece together the whole story here
It's like some kind of
Uh. Also- I mean it's one- this one murderer. Yes very much so. But also there's more to it than that
there's like
there's like uhh..
euuh
*ominous sounds*
there's like uh..
oooh..
I hate walking by those shutters
I hate it
There's like um.. Some sorta like- you remember the uh.. What is it- the Dyatlov Pass incident.. like
*distant voice*
hi..
Hi?
The- the Russian incident where the campsite was just left comple-...
*cellphone ringing*
Is that ME?
That's ME
Oh my god jesus that scared the piss outta me
Alright STOP
*ringing continues*
Stop.
Stop stop stop stop I don't have time for you
Jesus
Okay
So yeah this ca- this- "This door's locked"
"There are three locks with sploches of paint"
I don't think I've ever managed to get all three keys
to be able to unlock that door
*sigh*
But there is something else around here- I can't remember what
I think if I go down
there's like.. A basement. Yeah
"It's open"
So there's a basement, not that it's good to go in the basement, but
it does exist
eee..
*water droplets*
eeh..
*spooky ambiance*
Oh hi okay- we're getting the flashes again down here?
Good
Great
GREAT
GREAT GOOGLY MOOGLY
What is this?
Idon'tlikethis
I think I remember this? I don't know
*groan of distress*
Oh boy
Whatwasthat?
Hello?
"There's a note tucked into the corner. Read it?"
"My name is David Ashford. My address is 3656 Coburn Hollow Road Deer Creek, Massachusetts I think I'm going to die here. I'm hiding this"-
"note in hopes somebody will uncover it and know the truth about what happened to us. Somebody came to our campsite in the middle of the night and..."
"Doesn't seem like the note was finished"
YEAH I WONDER WHY
I WONDER WHY IT WASN'T FINISHED
I WONDER WHY THAT COULD HAVE POSSIBLY BEEN-
AAAAAAH! FUCKING NO!!!
*really game?*
*why you do this?*
Uuuugh...
Okay..
Anyway I think
I think that might be the end of what I..
What I got goin' on here I ran outta...
ran outta time. I only wanted a short little adventure into this but look
Power Drill Massacre; it's a really tough game. It's tough.
It's a tough game.
Tough game for tough people but I'm not tough enough
So thank you everybody so much for watching
Hope you enjoyed this little stream
Hope you enjoyed me dying horribly over and over and over again- that was always fun
Let me know how I did down in the comments below
Thanks again
And as always I will see you..
In the next video
Buh-bye!
bye
bye guys
bye..
Bye.